[Applause]
[Music]
I can feel your energy back there I'm
just jumping my god what a beautiful
beautiful group um and it hasn't been
three years it's been twelve but you
know those numbers don't matter you know
it's one of those one-hit wonders it
happens overnight that you've been
working for about 12 years on so I just
wanted to clarify that so you guys I'm
gonna do something that's really
vulnerable and I hope that you're
willing to be with me here about two
months ago I downloaded the spoken word
like I was sitting at the office and I
went is the through line of my life
like I've been in you know I sell
something that covers up and you
know so this thing and I the spoken
word came through and I would like to
perform that for you guys today are you
really okay so here we go people always
ask me how to get rich well I want to
tell you how and believe you me this
is going to keep you on the edge of
your seat because you cannot make this
up I grew up in Arkansas poorest
with parents it did some good
some bad some crazy and some
really weird dad left us in a pile
of
some mom completely lost her and
she married this who molested me
and that was some really messed up
so messed up that I actually started
believing I was worthless as and I
actually let that man walk me down the
aisle into deeper married bankrupt
and divorced by 20 years old I tried to
kill myself just to get out of that
but then I met a rich man who I thought
was the
but he beat me and told me I was a piece
of and I believed him and still we
made two kids that shed a lot of light
on all that dark I mean they were
some holy so holy I had to get him
out of that because we all know you
can't survive that homeless and
scared shitless I felt hopeless is
then I met a drummer who had little
money but he offered a song away from
that and we had a little girl and
she was truly the and we grew a
family that was funny
despite all the but I still thought
money was a ticket out of that so I
pushed through I sold out and I clogged
for that only to find myself
bankrupt again ya broke as like I
literally didn't have so I screamed
to God and I said I'm done with all that
and there was nothing left to do
but face my like I had to clean up
that and I knew I had to change
that
I had to flip that script breakout and
finally own my and I realized what
I was taught about life was a big crock
of that I was the one who attracted
and created all that and I
discovered happiness comes from inside
and not from outside and finally I
was happy and no one could take away
that and that in itself was a
miracle holy
now here's where the gets really
good see I had an idea there was a live
issue I didn't like the smell of so
I had to solve that now everybody
thought I was crazy as because I'd
follow my family around the house asked
him when they were going to take his
no joke
I think please spray this before you
ship and guess what it turned out to be
the
but I didn't have experience or even
know jack-shit but I was creative as
see I'd follow the hunt that seemed
craziest then I got it
energy is the real and following
energy was the only I needed to
know and I did not have time for
so boy I practiced that so
much so that now I am happier than
and alive is and I've made a
shitload of money while being turned on
is
[Applause]
all by following what's resident is
and yes sometimes I still get scared of
and I still lose my but that
does not stop me because my gut
knows more than all that other and
I can honestly stand here and tell you
yes I am rich as but I mean rich in
every way you can mean that
surrounded by aliveness and being turned
on is and I know following what's
alive is the only thing even worthless
so do you really want to be richest
I mean do you really want to be
richest yet they get your together
by dropping that that's dragging
you down stop worrying about outside
and trust that only you know your
trust it only you know your
and dive into the that turns you on
I mean focus on that lights you up
and when that is resonant for God's
sakes go for that and do not hold
your back because you are worthy of
and you are powerful as and
you can change this because you are
the did you hear me you are the
and there is alive inside of
you that holds the key to all that
you desire and if you just tuned in and
follow that that turns you on then
you're going to be rich too no
[Applause]
so there's my story in a nutshell so you
guys know me as the CEO of poopourri
right and I've been in deep I've
been in good I've experienced a
whole gamut of and what you don't
know is that I after my second
bankruptcy when I was 38 years old I was
done when I said I screamed to God and
said I'm done with that like I
literally was done I was like I never
want to go back into business I do not
want to be a part of that world because
it's painful this is my second damn
bankruptcy I keep falling on my face I
don't want any part of that so I went on
a spiritual sabbatical and I found peace
within myself I had no desire for
business and I'll never forget the day I
was a dinner party and my brother-in-law
said can bathroom odor be trapped and I
felt this like zing up my arm and like
everything went to hi-def and I'm like
yeah it can be and I can do that with
oils and of course he said really you
think so
I was like yeah I know so so I started
moving towards this idea to today you
see poopourri we sold 40 million bottles
or even more we're a household name it's
a breakthrough category creator but I
never intended any of that all I was
doing was following an alive idea
so we're trucking along and I'm having a
good time because remember I told you
when I was back there I said I am NOT
going back there I had the luxury of
losing everything and I say luxury
because we rarely have that time when we
have a clean slate like I was wiped out
wiped clean so I was able to rebuild on
something different so when I came back
into business I said I'm gonna do fun
because what I know is you don't
know when you're gonna lose all the
and what's worse than losing everything
is losing everything and realizing that
you
didn't even have a good time now I'm not
joking like that's what really sucks
okay so I was like I'm not doing it like
literally if it doesn't feel good I'm
not doing it
and it wasn't any strategy it was
literally like I am NOT gonna go back
there I'm not gonna sell out I'm not
gonna push through and I'm not gonna
claw through that anymore like I'm
done so I did it different there was
sort of like this intuition that came in
it's just I'm just not going back there
so I don't care so I had this luxury and
one day my friend calls me and he wanted
to do a video of me he said where do you
want to talk about I said I want to talk
about success like it's boring here I'm
talking to you guys about it Lia's yeah
me there he is how do you know which
idea to follow and I'm trying to tell
him in my body I'm like well you've kind
of like you're pulled towards and you
know and you feel excited but you don't
he goes I don't know what you're talking
about I was like yeah I'm either so I
started using my company as a petri dish
I started going in and kind of really
when we start making business decisions
I was like how did we know to go make
this viral video how did we know how to
do that so I sort of was observing as we
were operating and what I realized is
that it seemed that the ideas we
followed we were all excited about and
passionate about seemed to work out they
had some sort of weird resiliency and
that was like why is that and whenever
we tried to do something because that's
what you do when you're in this category
or that's what you do in business you
know what everybody says you're supposed
to do like it rarely worked out for us
so I wondered if we were an anomaly and
then I had a theory our ideas alive a
question
so I called dr. bruce lipton he's a
cellular biologist and I said our ideas
alive and he said why do you ask
I said because it seems like some ideas
that I have are actually they they work
out more and I said I have a theory that
those 75 percent or whatever that number
is now businesses that fail it's because
that was a good plan it wasn't an alive
passionate idea inside of them I said
also I think viruses are considered
living of since found out they're not I
go but how can that travel from person
to person but an idea or a meme or a
thought that travels isn't considered
living where does life begin and where
does it end and he said these are really
great questions and he said there may be
something to teach you here in physics
first of all he said everything is a
living vibration everything is an
energetic vibration and every living
thing is seeking more lifeforce energy
so who knew that then he taught me about
resonance and dissonance so we're gonna
go into a physics class I know y'all
thought I was gonna tell jokes all
day we're not we're gonna talk about
physics real quick as soon as they
change the slide younger so he taught me
about dissonance and he's a dissonance
is when you take two energy waves that
are traveling at different speeds and
different wavelengths those two together
create less energy than they do apart
did you hear that
do you have energy you're going along
you hook up with someone that's like
this you literally have less energy than
when you started that's got distance
then you tell me about resonance he said
resonance is when you take two energy
waves and they're traveling at the same
speed and the same wavelength you put
those two together and they actually
have more energy together than they do
apart I am like what thank you hear that
they literally have more energy together
than they do
somehow they're amplified so I started
thinking back to my life prior you're in
the bankruptcy when I was 38 and I
started realizing about dissonance of it
went away and I started noticing
whenever I would make decisions they
were literally from my head up there was
no alive feeling in my body
it's literally like what you say I need
to do this I need a mentor I need to go
around and what what do I have to do had
to do this okay great great great
everything was outside myself and it was
extremely cerebral what happened is I
was victim right I blamed everybody life
was against me it ended up in bankruptcy
was heavy tense and I was always
protecting like I was just worried every
single second and I realized that that's
what happens when I'm making decisions
not from my full body and not worried
about what becomes alive if everything
is so strategic I end up like this and
I'll tell you in our business we
practiced this so much that whenever
we're in distance we call it struggle or
wonky world like we notice it and we'll
kind of do like a Zen painting and
scratch it and I'll tell you one example
we were going into the UAE and my
attorney calls me and says we're gonna
have to give the formula up to the
government of Saudi Arabia and I'm like
why and he said it's just legal we have
to don't worry I'm gonna find you an
attorney and we found a female attorney
which I was super excited right I'm like
you go girl
so we found a female attorney we have
the call law set up I'm gonna have to
give away my formula which my formulas
my trade secret kind of like Kentucky
Fried Chicken I'm in my car I'm driving
to work my assistant ten minutes after
the call was take place the calls not
happening and she calls me panicked she
was I don't know what happened I mean I
literally called the hotel before the
call I got through I've tried every
number I've tried three phones and I go
just
calm down settle down choose the call
will not go through back if something's
not right just stop I say call the
attorney time to find us another
attorney she's like what and I said yeah
something's not right here something is
dissonant like I can feel it something's
not right
so my attorney knows me he goes finds
another attorney two months later he
comes in he's like Suzy you're not gonna
believe this
he said you know he said we got the new
attorney and we don't have to give up
the formula had we given up the formula
it would have been public knowledge but
what I did is I realize that there was
struggle in this phone call and whenever
there's struggle I stop and go hold on
something's not quite right this is how
intuitive I'm talking and then the
opposite of that is resonance resonance
is constructive interference in what I
realize is when we are going about ideas
that feel resonant like things just feel
alive like remember there's two energy
waves we're sitting here and all of a
sudden we get an idea and it's like oh
my god you can feel the energy in the
room rays have y'all felt that before
you know it everybody's like buzzing and
we're on fire we're like oh everybody's
working you're working night and day and
night and day and it doesn't matter
because you're pulled towards that what
I call an alive idea you felt in who you
felt it yeah see there's something to
that this is the physics so what happens
is before the alive idea
you're just trucking along that alive
idea Compton Wow like I am amplified
it's the same thing with people within
groups if you're in struggle within a
group watch that get the group together
that is amplified together because
they're creating a field of resonance
what I've discovered is whenever I'm in
a resonant situation and doing something
that turns me on like life is for me
like it feels like I've got a skip in my
step everything just sort of works out
the first example I have of that as
girls do poop the company was about
eight years old
competition was coming in and I felt
something inside of me I'm like we got
to get the show on the road like what
are we doing we've been sitting around
in boutiques like we got a truck and I
find these guys we go camp out for two
weeks and in two weeks we wrote a script
built the website cast cast for the
video and we filmed a four-day video in
four different locations and that became
the viral hit girls do poop the reason
that's so exciting is because we did all
of that work that you think is pretty
impossible in a two-week period we did
it because of resonance another
situation is we had a video a music
video interview scene is called imagine
where you can go and this was a music
video but have you seen it would she
just get the joke
well that's what happened so I take my
team I always take them off site so I
took them off team we're in Hawaii we're
there for about a week we're riding and
riding riding we don't come up with a
song I tell my team I want to make a
music video nobody's made of consumer
goods product with a music video they're
like you're crazy I'm like it's fun hell
virgin did it with her you know thing
like we can do it for a poop spray so we
got it why'd we camp out my team comes
home a week later and they're like this
what's going on they said we don't have
a song
I can't we have ten pages of rhymes
what's a song it's a rhyme right like
don't worry dude we got it so I was
filming in LA and I'm on side two NBC
studios and I'm sitting with the
producer because it's an all-day thing
and I said you know I need a songwriter
one that should be signed that's not
because you start dealing with all about
it you know it's dissonant and he goes
you know what I'm a producer the voice I
know the perfect guy his name's Jeff
Lewis I said Jeff Lewis's is awesome
he was yep two hours later we're in the
elevator NBC studios that producers like
Susie and what and he goes Jeff Lewis
like what what are you talking about
right there's Jeff Lewis so I meet Jeff
Lewis we and if we make the video it's
another viral hit it's amazing but what
happened is it was fun you know I'm
saying there was another strategy like
we have to do this and we have to pull
these numbers and we have to do this
we're literally working through
synchronicity and magic it's an
experiment it's vibrant it's a startup
energy all the time it's endless upload
creativity's just going we get out
cameryn duddy they're just an uptown
funk you know what is it four billion
views he did it for like 1/4 of his
price he's probably like kill me right
now but anyway he was like this is a
dream job everything just sort of worked
out so what I've discovered I started
going okay residents and dissonance
residents and dissonance and I was like
how do you know whether you're in
residence and I figured out there's four
signs for me and I want you to try these
on for yourself
that tell me if I'm in a resident
situation and the first one as I'm
turned on and lit up remember how I said
that energy increases like that's when
you see yourself researching every night
you become with poopourri I was obsessed
no one I didn't want a business I never
ever ever thought about it being a
business everybody thought I was crazy
but I was obsessed about whether I could
do this thing or not once I figured it
out then I knew it had to come into the
world but I wasn't thinking of that I
was literally like oh my god I can make
this happen I can make this happen
that's where you get on these roles
where you're just into the work and
nobody and you are lit up you don't need
caffeine you don't need coffee you don't
need sleep
you are just rolling and going the
second one is body sensations what I've
noticed have you been around people and
they go oh my god I've got chill bumps
right you tell an idea of something
they're like oh my god I've got chills
like yeah that body sensation mine comes
iing up my arm I don't know where yours
go sometimes they're at the front of my
legs so sometimes I'll be sitting there
we'll be in a meeting and when I'm in
meetings I'm gauging the room like a
shaman from energy levels but yeah I
don't feel it I don't feel it I'm gonna
fill it and the idea pop up on the oh
okay hold on let's lean into that like I
felt something right here I felt
something in my arm and legs there's
also a pulling towards everybody can
jump on to that the third one are signs
of synchronicity right
so people used to call this Suzie's
world of course that happens in Suzie's
world of course it is I know it happened
in your world too so what happens is
when you're in resonance things just
kind of work out it's I don't know you
guys are probably all too young but do
you remember mr. Magoo I didn't even
remember mr. Magoo cartoon yeah we have
like 10 okay good
well mr. Magoo he was so amazing because
he would be driving down a highway he
did these big glasses where he couldn't
see he'd be driving on a highway you
couldn't see anything and you're
thinking he's gonna go off the bridge
and then a boat will come underneath him
right and he was land right on it so
that was the whole mr. Magoo cartoon so
what happens is you need a rider
you need a song producer and all of a
sudden he's in the elevator or he's
sitting on the plane next to you or like
oh my god my cousin did that or you know
that that happens there's no exhaustive
searching like it's just it's like it'll
literally come to you if you say open
and look and the fourth thing is that
idea keeps knocking on your door it does
not leave you alone how many times have
you heard somebody say oh my god I've
had this idea for six years I haven't
ever done it or 10 years or somebody
I'll finally come out with it and
they're like oh my god you know I
thought of this idea 12 years ago and it
hasn't left me alone that's another sign
of resonance that idea and you are a
perfect match so it's gonna stick with
you now here's what's cool about all
this remember when I told you about
resonance and that the energy wave has
to match it has to have the same
wavelength and the same speed but when
it matches it creates more energy
together than it did apart okay hold on
for a second
I'll explain to you what that means my
interpretation is that means if you were
not able to pull that idea off then it
would have never in the first place been
a resonant match do you I mean like I
feel chill bumps with that like I feel
it
that's the truth because it would not be
attracted to you so all those ideas you
have and you dream up and people tell
you all this stuff you know don't worry
about it because literally if that idea
came to you you have everything within
your power to bring that into the world
because that idea is resonant with you
here's another thing that I think is
freaking cool do you remember how I said
the two wave legs you've got one
separate then you've got the other one
just like two people what we forget
about is we're bringing 50% of energy to
the party guess what that ID is bringing
the other 50% of the energy so it's not
all up to you when do you guys get that
yeah so we always think I have to do it
I have to pull it off I have to make
this happen right what you don't
understand is that idea if you allow it
is also bringing its own energy to the
party if you just be open and follow the
signs and follow the resonance this is
where trust your gut comes in we don't
hear a lot about intuition we're
starting to hear a little more about
intuition business some people call this
intuition I explained it as physics or
that I saw it in physics because I think
that helps our Western mind because
we're so in our head but really you are
born with an internal GPS system that we
abandon when we're young we're taught
don't listen to that oh you're silly
you're crazy you're crazy
my toss to you is that you start doing
anything to clear away whatever is
keeping that from being alive in you
because that right there is your power
source that is 100% that is going to
guide you better than any mentor
in the world now that's the truth so the
mentor can give you advice and when they
give you advice you you get into your
body and either it feels good or it
doesn't and if it doesn't feel good you
turn around and run you go thank you so
much I'm going to go over here because
you can trust yourself so I'm going to
ask you one more time do you really want
to be Rich's do you I didn't
believe you do you really really want to
be richest yet yeah who's this guy bring
him to your party then get your
together by dropping this that's
dragging you down
stop worrying about outside and
trust that only you know your and
dive into the that turns you on and
focus on that lights you up focus
on that lights you up and when that
is resident for God's sakes go for
that and do not hold back because
you are worthy of you are powerful
is and you you alone can change
this because you are the you
are the
and there is alive inside of you
that's the key to all of that that
you desire and if you just tuned in and
turn on and move towards that a live
then you're going to be rich - no
[Applause]
thank you I think they said we got a
couple of questions or something
was there a situation in which the
residents didn't quite work for you why
do we have to spray before okay that's
an easy one you don't have to but it
actually worked the best before because
it's actually trapping the odor on the
surface of the water okay so you're
actually handling the situation before
it begins but it'll still work after
it's not as effective your as fun as
oh thank you how do you wait how do
you find best pick your team to increase
residence a certain idea project what I
do is when I told you I literally sit
around in meetings and III am very vocal
I say you know I'm not feeling the
energy here I'm not feeling this in the
room right now and then we just keep
tossing out more ideas and in our in our
environment you don't have to have the
great idea
we are literally playing but once we get
something it's like literally hooking
onto a jet pack where we start riding
when it is I go oh my god I feel it like
I feel chills our buddies like I feel
chills we feel excited and that's when
we start riding that idea and going
deeper and before that we're just
playing and we're just tossing if there
are a lot of shits like you up how do
you choose which one is the best I
like that I read you can have a lot of
shifts you know you can be working on
you know my mentor says you can work on
five major things at one time and I
literally would bounce back and forth to
which one's turning you on in the moment
right like I oh my god I got this idea
for this one you work on that project
and oh my god I had this idea for this
one you don't have to do it in such a
linear fashion that's the way artists do
if you look at painters they're painting
several paintings you know all over the
place they're not necessarily sitting
down working on one so I would continue
doing it okay I don't know how many we
okay we're done okay
did you Brut step oh i bootstrapped I've
never had alone never had an investor
completely self-funded
Spray before you spray oh that's a good
one
okay anyway I think we're done thank you
so much I appreciate it
[Applause]